est-ce que les chroniqueurs d'été pmp
joue un rôle et nora a dit que c'était
du spectacle donc forcément que vous
vous forciez le trait est ce que vous ai
parlé ce pour moi oui voilà en plus
sympa est ce que vous êtes tous dans la
vie comme à l'antenne moi pareil hommage
à casal dit je trouve beaucoup plus
riches dans la vie quand on voit par
exemple monsieur jean luc delarue qui
était voilà qu avait des problèmes avec
la drogue et qui était très dépressif et
qui à l'antenne paraissait le gendre
idéal
alors on parle de quoi on parle de
schizophrénie ont passé un rôle terre
qui ont fait le spectacle ont fait le
show et 3g loup tué un amour dans la vie
tu es un bisounours tu es très calme et
sur ce plateau etc voilà pour ça au site
a été embauchée on en avait parlé à
l'époque avec cyril tu prends tu campe
le rôle du mec toujours toujours
offusqué par falloir rien et non mais je
veux dire quelque chose est bon c'est
pas moi qui le donnait ce rôle c'est
vrai que il et il valait se révèle ici
je pense white avec un comics à tous le
dimanche
voilà non mais la porte maillot je dis
la vérité
franchement moi je suis aussi agité plus
hors antenne que à l'antenne c'est
possible oui c'est possible oui c'est
possible mais valérie bénaïm je trouve
franchement vous êtes pareils ben vous
fait des boulettes tout ça non mais
c'est vrai bernard montiel il est poussé
le même
ah ouais géraldine maillet asselah mais
vous la péter un peu plus à l'antenne
non mais c'est vrai vous vous trouvez
gilles que vous jouez un rôle est ce que
parce que j'ai en moi je trouve je vous
trouve excédents dans l'émission vous
êtes vraiment quelqu'un sur qui je peux
compter à chaque fois mais c'est vrai
que vous visez vous avez des plus
grosses colères ici quand loge parfois
pourquoi mais je suis moi même ici alors
je sais pas si c'est parce que ça me
réveille mais quand je suis chez moi en
regardant la télé on c'est vrai à merde
je m'emporte tout seul je dis mais l
ennemi c de boccolini en a marre et
jamais vous êtes boccolini est ce que
j'aime c'est autre exemple donc j'adore
et nohra mais je ne supporte pas parce
que depuis que vous avez quitté touche
pas à mon poste est en permanence à ses
fossés un rôle c'est une comédie et
sylvain powell tête alors là pas pour
moi jamais vous n'avez su ce que
j'allais dire rien n'est scénarisé rien
n'est pas là rien n'est pas pareil je
vous le dit daniel monde et nous mêmes
et n'aura même pas quand vous dites si
tu veux mon chat je pense qu'on confond
personnages et personnalités cyril c'est
choisir des personnalités et et qui
s'habille très bien non mais moi même ma
mère existe vraiment il ya parfois il ya
des jamais rien pour battre john hurt
existe au maire existe vraiment
meilleurs frac de la soirée d'adelboden
qu'elle dit est ce que parfois dans les
interviews
c'est un positionnement compliquée par
rapport à tous pas mon poste mais
parfois laissés là par les trompettes
j'ai senti parfois que c'était la
justification été parfois peut-être un
peu compliqué en tous les cas elles et
moi a trouvé pour eux et non me pose
toujours la même question mais c'est
parce que évidemment je vous le dis j'ai
bouffé respect non mais bien sûr pour
fait du spectacle évidemment je suis
différente dans la vie vous le savez
très bien on s'est connus il ya
maintenant presque dix ans que ce que
gêne était à l'antenne un peu comme
gilles après c'est pas une justification
c'est voilà c'est ma réponse et moi et
tu le sais très bien on en a parlé
ensemble je faisais des qualifs juste
une petite anecdote qui est très rigolo
christine angot qui vous offre
constamment attaquée non tu mets un peu
attaquées mais très gentiment moi je les
aime beaucoup c'est qu'après cette
séquence où elle matin qu elle me dit
non joue pas vraiment un rôle est les
jumeux faire un énorme calandre antennes
et côté de dire à quel point on sait
mais bien qu'elle viendrait me voir au
théâtre et je me suis dit ah vous
dirais-je ou rallye va pas jouer aussi
on fait de la télé vous savez très bien
qu'il ait mis si après je vous le dis
voilà c'est sur moi je parlais juste un
truc aussi c'est vrai que quand vous
avez sur les plateaux forcément on est
l'émission média qui juge les autres
émissions
donc forcément qui vont a pas attaqué il
aura pas ce qu'il veut c'est ce qu'a dit
laurent qui le dit c'est vrai que tu
nous a beaucoup attaqué est ce que ça te
gêne pour la promo parce que tu attaques
et beaucoup d'émissions
c'est normal c'est le principe est
maintenant tout le monde rentre aussi je
vous le dis dans ce truc où il critique
où il juge les émissions télé ce qui se
faisait pas du tout avant avril son
niveau soultz et qui sont quand même un
peu obsédé par cette émission parce que
moi ça fait quand même plus d'un an que
je suis partant et quand ils voient même
la sortie de charles consigny qui me
parlait de tpm p j'avais à lui dire mais
j'attends moi j'y suis plus appel cyril
il n'a jamais regardé je pense que c'est
parce que j'ai d'ailleurs c'est marrant
de voir à quel point ils sont en train
de revenir sur sept et michel console il
m'appellera pas si ils veulent savoir
c'est moi les ficelles
non mais c'est ça je suis d'accord avec
vous c'est ça qui est fou à l'ailé
chiron va clore le débat tu juges
jean-michel qu'il trouvait juste parce
que j'ai quand il leur a dit que c'est
des personnages c'est pas les
personnages mais comme c'est toujours
des débats événement qu'on veut débattre
et qu'on veut l'emporter obligé de
donner deux armes en effet la force fait
que du coup on s'emporte un peu on force
un peu le trait mais c'est pas les
personnages on est vraiment comme ça et
qu'il est vraiment aussi compte dans la
vraie vie
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
dernier truc je voulais juste savoir
alors en revanche je ne remets pas en
cause notre sincérité on n'est pas les
ventriloques de cyril hanouna
or certains si on ne m'attendais à
yathrib vous pouvez pas vous pouvez voir
surtout à moi qui était là bien avant la
plupart-- qui a fait ses meilleurs
pendant huit ans je connais les ficelles
et ça nous est tous arrivé de
effectivement de défendre des positions
pour soutenir cyril ce que je trouve
normal où on n'était pas forcément
persuadé ce qu'on dit et moi je vous dis
je
faut le faire par solidarité oui je vous
ai jamais demandé de défendre quelqu'un
ou de fracasser quelque chose à nancy
s'est jamais tombée laura non mais s'il
n'avait pas coûté très fâché avec arthur
non tu ne t'étais pas très contents si
on mais voilà et après alors pas très
contente pas de la sorte au losc sur le
plateau et nous embarque dans une
question j'ai répondu les premières
j'avais à chaque fois défendu arthur
parce que quand elle travaille avec
quelqu'un je la défense et derrière du
principe que je crache pas dans la soupe
la danse et donc et je défendrai
toujours arthur pour avoir travaillé
avec lui parce qu'il a été toujours
extrêmement élégant et en l'occurrence
après cyril me laisser faire même si
après on s'engueulait mais à chaque fois
il me laissait facilement titillent un
cousin mais j'attends je voulais experts
mais c'est vrai que voilà forcément je
préfère mais vous faites ce que vous
voulez parce qu'ils nous engueuler sur
le plateau bien sûr des quelque chose
n'êtes pas d'accord vous nous engueuler
vraiment bah oui d'ailleurs merci en
tout cas d'avoir un jet ça c'était site
est intéressant moi de voir ça je trouve
et c'est vrai qu'on m'ait choisi pour
dites ce que vous voulez vous la pressez
à vos risques et périls pour appeler non
mais non mais ce que je sais moi j'ai eu
la chance de vous remplacer de temps en
temps c'est à cette place là on oublie
d'être un peu au milieu et des deux
bon on va pas se positionner à chaque
fois c'est comme ça aussi moi je me
positionne un peu et fait c'est
franchement peut-être un peu trop
parfois mais je continuerai